[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in recent years you've probably been
hearing a lot of hype about deep
learning but what is it really all about
and here's another curious question why
has deep learning only now just come
into the spotlight seemingly from
nowhere in this video we'll answer these
questions and learn the impacts that
deep learning has on our world they'll
also be a guest appearance from Justin
shank who has worked as a contractor
finto finally we'll take a look at some
cutting edge deep learning applications
that are happening right now let's get
into it
for most people the terms a I machine
learning and deep learning are
interchangeable before continuing it's
important that we make some concrete
definitions artificial intelligence or
AI is an umbrella term for a branch of
computer science its aim is for machines
to mimic human cognition with a focus on
complex problem-solving machine learning
is a subset of AI it focuses on how to
make computers learn on their own
without the need for hand coded
instructions machine learning systems
analyze vast amounts of data and learn
from previous mistakes
the result is an algorithm that
completes its tasks effectively deep
learning which is what we're going to be
focusing on is a subset within machine
learning this technology attempts to
mimic the activity of neurons in our
brains using matrix mathematics this
arrangement is called a neural network
and dates all the way back to 1957
the modern and more complex networks are
known as deep networks but weren't
proven practical until around 2012 so to
answer the second question why has deep
learning only just come about now deep
networks have only become feasible
because of two reasons an increase in
computing power and vast amounts of data
since the introduction of the first
Intel ship in 1971 the number of
transistors have roughly doubled every
two years this doubling of transistors
on the chip essentially means an
exponential increase in computing power
this idea was first proposed by Gordon
Moore co-founder of Intel and is
commonly referred to as Moore's law from
the mid-2000s computers became powerful
enough to make neural networks perform
but the lack of training data meant that
these nets couldn't be used for anything
actually useful and this brings us to
the second point the explosion of the
internet eventually led to vast amounts
of data that could be used for training
purposes so why do our networks need so
much data essentially the more data
there is the more robustly the network
can be trained put yourself in the shoes
of a deep learning network trying to
recognize a cat for example if you've
only seen three cats would only have a
few camera angles and lighting
conditions to work with something as
simple as seeing a cat from a different
angle or in a different light would
throw you off but on the other hand if
you've seen thousands of different cats
you'd have a much easier time
recognizing one this is the importance
of data computers aren't as intuitive as
humans and need more examples in the
field of deep learning data is the
essence that allows machines to learn
you could look at it this way if data is
a new form of oil the Internet is a huge
oil reserve and deep learning systems of
the machines that run on this data so
the true field of deep learning all
began in 2012 in this year deep learning
exploded into the spotlight when an
artificial neural network was used in
the competition to recognize the world's
biggest data set of images it was the
first time a neural network was used in
this competition and it blew all
previous types of algorithms out of the
water at this moment the world realized
that deep nets were useful after all
this was the birth of the modern AI
movement
thanks to the exponential growth of
computing power and the vast amounts of
data deep learning networks have gained
the ability to recognize objects and
translate speech and real-time they're
everywhere from our phones to smart home
systems that's all the stuff that you've
heard before the thing that many people
may not know is that deep learnings
impact is far wider than most people
think
vast amounts of data can be found in all
corners of Industry deep learning
affects anything from oil exploration to
energy grids social media information
medical records code compiling server
farm power management border policing
and so on the organization and
interpretation of this data is very
useful to businesses at all levels the
problem though is that this data is
unlabeled and unstructured this means
that it can't be used to train machine
learning programs that depend on
supervised instructions deep learning
networks can avoid this drawback because
they excel at label Asst unsupervised
learning especially when it comes to
prediction and pattern recognition to
explain further let's hear from Justin
shank hi my name is Justin shank I'm an
AI researcher at Pelt Ariana and an
Intel software innovator so deep
learning it's quite inspired by an
understanding of the brain the neural
network idea we can compare it also in
terms of its ability to learn certain
representations and the brain for
example is at a young age a child can
learn a word after hearing at only one
or two times and that's considered
amazing for machine learning standards
to be able to generalize from very few
instances of data so deep learning
allows us to find patterns and also
relatively limited data making
generalizations that's a that's one of
the amazing things about deep learning
ok so let's take a look at some of the
emerging hardware for deep learning the
Intel Murphy Dias neural computing is
Intel's effort to provide D playing on
the go simply put it's a standard USB
Drive that plugs into a computer that
enables rapid prototyping of deep neural
network interface applications locally
that is it doesn't require users to
connect to the cloud so if you have a
drone for example that is flying over
the water and trying to see if anyone is
drowning to drop them the life preserver
you want that to be able to compute what
it sees in real-time without having to
send that data back to some server Intel
has also purchased navona systems for
400 million dollars the varna chips are
said to be able to transfer data in and
out at about 2.4 terabytes per second at
a very low latency that's supposed to be
about 10 times faster than traditional
chips if we leave the rest of Apple
aside for a moment the neural engine in
the iPhone tends a 12 Bionic chip is
impressive it signifies a shift towards
deep learning being local and integral
to mobile capabilities uber an uber eats
deep learning system called Michelangelo
enables the cars to arrive on time by
analyzing data from millions of previous
trips and applying it to your specific
situation it also knows where all the
drivers are and what trips they're
completing at any particular time it
uses this information to calculate which
optimum driver should pick you up how
else do you think the cars arrive so
quickly the technology is also making
personal health care easier data from
wearables provide patient specific
information directly to their healthcare
professionals deep learning can even
help predict a range of diseases by
analyzing eyeball retinas or it can
diagnose eye or other diseases as
accurately as doctors marking a
milestone inside this hospital in
Shenzhen in southern China doctors here
getting a hand from artificial
intelligence for example we have vivid
images the AI system will sort them and
select the pictures showing a high
possibility of cancer we only need to
check five selected images for a
diagnosis a eye is able to learn from
numerous amounts of data that's what
humans can't do now the accuracy of
early detection of esophageal cancer has
reached 90%
roughly the same level of diagnosis made
by human doctors since the launch it
served 400,000 patients
right now it detects breast cancer and
prostate cancer but we could also work
on any other cancer type that we train
models for a team of pathologists that
went through thousands of images
teaching the computer what cancer cells
look like it's going to make the doctors
much quicker they're going to make them
better which is going to overall benefit
the patient the mission is to increase
the accuracy and availability of cancer
diagnosis and save people's lives
I can hardly think of anything that's
more motivating MRI CT and EEG scan data
is used to learn patterns and diagnose
diseases such as cancer and heart
disease it seems like there's almost no
limit to what deep networks can achieve
in the healthcare industry okay so let's
look at some more fascinating new
possibilities from just the past six
months or so that have just been made
possible through deep neural networks so
style transfer is something already
known to most of you taking the style of
one artistic image and imposing on
something completely different but what
about motion transfer this is now
recently possible a recent neural
network can take a professional dancer
and transpose their motion onto people
who well can't dance take a look
[Music]
[Music]
a similar thing has been done with
animals for potential use in video games
this neural network is controlling this
arm learns to pick up objects in a very
real way it can't just use its hand to
pick up the objects because the object
is too wide and grasp can't fit in order
to complete the task it actually had to
demonstrate learning and figure out that
it had to break up the object before it
could pick it up another reason neural
net uses the data it receives from Wi-Fi
signals bouncing off humans to see their
motion in the dark how about generating
an animated face just from an outline
deep neural Nets also help in denoising
usually cleaning up an image like this
is a very labor-intensive or impossible
it can now be done in an instant when
neural networks this has obvious
applications for cleaning up low-light
images and smartphone cameras but can
also remove other noise including
randomly generated text it's important
to note that while doing all of this the
network have no access to the original
photos it doesn't stop there though a
pair of neural networks working together
in the same system managed to give super
resolution to pixelated images it's not
hard to see how this network and the
previous noise reduction Network could
be used to bring perfect photos to
anyone just look at the detail extracted
in these shots
[Music]
[Music]
imagine having a choppy video at a few
frames per second and then creating
super slow motion just from that this is
now possible thanks to some neural
networks playing video the network was
trained on thousands of videos so it
learned what made a good slow-motion
video and now it can apply it to learned
knowledge to any video the problem of
deep fakes has now been tackled by
neural nets I mentioned this as a
solution in my deep fakes video and a
lot of people argued that it couldn't be
done but a few months later here we are
enter round off we have some new
artistic neural net loosen ations
pretty interesting to look at
so what can we say in conclusion deep
Nantz as a technology has the ability to
complete highly-skilled work that was
traditionally expensive it could lead to
new scientific breakthroughs and a
drastic fall in the price of goods and
services but there remains a question if
these systems are so good and become
better than us at our jobs what are we
going to do this is probably one of the
hardest questions to answer the solution
could involve a natural creation of
whole new industries that don't exist
yet or an enabler for us to do even more
intellectual work than ever before
that's a whole discussion for another
day regardless the discovery and
recognition of patterns and regularities
in the world around us lies at the heart
of scientific and technological progress
it's how we advance and innovate it's
also an area where deep learning excels
the question isn't whether or not deep
learning is useful but what is the limit
to creativity in its applications so
that just about rounds out at the end of
the video I want to thank Intel for
helping out with this video and if you
want to check out the Intel compute
stick you can click the link below I'd
be interested to know if you guys have
come across any interesting applications
of deep learning lately I think this is
one of the most interesting fields to
watch and there's been advancing faster
than anything I've ever seen
alright thanks for watching this has
been - go go you've been watching cold
fusion if you just stumbled across this
channel and you're here for the first
time feel free to subscribe cheers guys
haven't
[Music]
you